it seems Halloween came a little early  this year for Jojo Fletcher and Jordan  Rogers just got home dinner normal this  bachelorette couple took Friday date  night to a whole new level dressing up  as Mighty Morphin Power Rangers  exploring our area of Dallas that were  in our date night restaurants that we  live on Saturday the pair took a trip to  Chipotle for breakfast uniquely  reinventing that dining experience  Chipotle doesn't have eggs so I brought  eggs for breakfast burrito  Chipotle take notes Jordan was so  determined to get eggs in his meal he  assembled his own burrito at the counter  captured in a full snapchat tutorial  this is a situation  but he did need a little help wrapping  the tortilla in the end the former  quarterback created his own Chipotle a  world's first to pull a breakfast  burrito